[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
un outsider de la política anti
establecimiento y alejado de los
partidos tradicionales todo fernández
logró entrar a la segunda vuelta por la
presidencia de colombia y los expertos
atribuyen gran parte de su éxito en las
urnas al trabajo de campaña realizado en
redes sociales como tick tock donde
logró una gran visibilidad mientras
evitaba varios debates en medios de
comunicación lo que generó críticas de
la población como lo hizo quien está
detrás de esta estrategia y estamos ante
un cambio de como serán las campañas
políticas a futuro aquí el análisis
empezamos
solo hace un par de años era
inimaginable mezclar la política con
'tik tok' la famosa red social que ganó
reconocimiento por los bailes de sus
usuarios y por permitir hacer playback
de contenidos previamente grabados pero
hoy la historia es otra vez porque estoy
muy viejo para tenerte y top
cuéntanos muy bueno vídeos como estos se
finalizaron en las semanas previas a la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales de colombia son parte de
la campaña del candidato rodolfo
hernández quien se enfrentará a gustavo
petro por el cargo más importante del
país el próximo 19 de junio aunque los
casi 6 millones de votos que recibió no
están estrictamente vinculados con los
likes y las vistas a sus vídeos expertos
resaltan su estrategia de comunicación
que hizo de esta red social un escenario
clave para lograr exposición nacional
luisa fernanda o le juez la directora de
comunicaciones de rodolfo hernández en
una entrevista a france 24 nos contó de
dónde nació la idea de publicar este
tipo de contenidos y siendo coherentes
con la premisa del que es el muy austero
tanto en el gobierno como en campaña
dijimos vamos por las redes sociales que
por supuesto tienen un gasto de personal
y de pauta pero en realidad es muy
mínimo entonces vivimos vamos a enfocar
la campaña presidencial como por lo
menos en un 90 por ciento
digital porque entramos en el víctor
porque nos dimos cuenta que la red
social estaba cogiendo muchísima fuerza
en sus audiencias a los públicos dijimos
por qué no llegar a ellos y por qué no
llegar a ahí que aparentemente se cree
que es una audiencia de jóvenes que no
tienen cédula y que no votan pero eso no
es así es una red social en donde hay
muchísimos adultos otros por su parte
consideran que el candidato se
ridiculizó al hacer este tipo de
contenidos pero esto según diego santos
consultor y emprendedor digital jugó a
su favor a diferencia del efecto que
hubiera logrado en otros candidatos a
continuación no se explica por qué no es
que se convierta en una constante porque
había contenido serio que se publica de
radón fernández pero la ritualización lo
que hacía es que atraía como imán a
muchas personas que no empezaban a ver
entonces esto crecía como la espuma
ahora bien hay que entender algo la
ridiculización no es para todos a óscar
iván si lo haga no le funciona la
ridiculización porque ya su tipo de
cierto reconocimiento y bagaje en el
mundo político colombiano es un término
de su persona que tiene la imagen una
imagen seria cuál es el problema que
estamos en un mundo de redes sociales
donde prima el entretenimiento y donde
la gente se fija más en el que lo hace
reír o entretener a uno
que en el serio que no le genera una
risa o no le genera una conexión y eso
no es necesariamente bueno ridiculizado
o no los expertos reconocen el éxito de
la campaña de rodolfo hernández luisa
fernanda también habló sobre los
factores que han influido en la conexión
con los votantes digamos que la magia
la clave realmente es
decir lo que otros candidatos dicen ya
sea de propuestas y posturas políticas
en un formato diferente
consumible logramos que haya una
horizontalidad entre el candidato y los
seguidores
no es como el candidato arriba y los
seguidores o el electorado abajo no es
así es rodolfo hernández a la par de si
le escribe en un dm se contesta que si
ponen un comentario se responde en
realidad online hay reacciones nosotros
todo el equipo estamos pendiente de
generar es de generar conversación
además dentro de los mismos post así no
sean del tema precisamente de del post
entonces eso hace que haya una cercanía
cambiamos de tema el programa de la onu
sobre el sida advirtió que hay una
estigmatización en la cobertura
mediática sobre el reciente brote de la
viruela del mono se trata del uso del
lenguaje e imágenes que según dijo
refuerzan estereotipos homofóbicos y
racistas por un lado al promover
imágenes de personas africanas con el
virus y por otro representaciones de
personas lgbti esto se dio sólo porque
se conoció que muchos de los primeros
casos positivos reportados en españa
fueron encontrados en sujetos que
visitaron un sauna de madrid exclusivo
para hombres y un festival en canarias
hay que resaltar que la viruela del mono
no es una enfermedad de transmisión
sexual y según la organización mundial
de la salud se puede contar a través del
contacto físico con alguien que tiene
síntomas o con objetos que han estado en
contacto con personas infectadas luisa
cabal directora regional para américa
latina y el caribe de onusida informó a
france24 sobre las consecuencias de este
tipo de situaciones cuando
estigmatizamos cuando culpabilizamos a
ciertos grupos de personas qué pasa que
perjudicamos una respuesta de salud
pública y cómo perjudicamos una
respuesta de salud pública porque las
poblaciones estigmatizadas deberán de ir
a los servicios entonces se enferman con
consecuencias para su vida y para su
salud se los por los proveedores de
salud pública quienes deben cuidar por
la salud adoptan muchas de estas
actitudes de matisse antes entonces está
estigmatizar aún más a estas personas
que deben ir a los servicios y por tanto
nuestra respuesta de salud pública y de
derechos se ve frenada y afectada el
estigma destruye lo que la ciencia logra
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
24 punto com
[Música]